WOB ladies and gents my name's Roy Roy
I'm dying soon [ __ ]
boo boo boo boo boo boo we're checking
out tekken 7 fated retribution trailer
today a lot of people have asked me to
check this one out
yeah um let's see all the hype of what's
going on here I used to play Tekken I
got all the way up to Tekken 5 remember
I went to your place once oh yeah we
play Tekken and I got my ass kicked
Adam played in years and I'm still like
I know the controls oh I love it because
everyone has their own different
fighting style and they didn't honor
those fighting styles but yeah let's see
what this trailers going on here is do
it
yeah I see kind of sin done you much
money they got for subtitles several
decades ago but x2 machine if I die
we'll see you attack Cena hear yourself
do a little yeah a little they like so
go straight do it you can do to keep
doable little Hollywood kiss
oh no come to here
oh my god excited he is here
fated retribution featuring Akuma
it's hearing Akuma does real he does see
you ago casiano
you're a [ __ ] too much to fire destiny
to epic the Tekken stories like I used
to follow like the stories to the
characters I would go online and read
all the details about everything that
you know you don't get in the game
itself
yeah cuz it's a fighting game so I love
the whole Tekken Lord although all the
stories it's me really interesting to
see how they include Akuma in that he
doesn't seem like he's just a bonus
character he seems like it's actually
our story you know it's cool to be like
this will be the one who can take down
hey Hachi
finally cuz that guy can never be like
no matter how many times you destroy him
he just keeps coming back I watched a
bunch of videos on like the lore of
Tekken in the storyline of jab it's
crazy
so Tekken cross street fighter yeah yeah
there's a second versus street fun yeah
Tekken vs. Street Fighter and this is
just kind of a continuation of that sort
of relationship that they developed yeah
being able to like continue to like hey
yo here's my character now that thing
the Tekken vs. Street Fighter was the
controls itself like it was a fun game
but I remember playing it and not being
fully into it sure it's because you're
matching up two very different control
planes with these two with these two
very good oh yeah yeah like the basics
are the same of like kick and punch but
the way though all the combos work all
the special moves work it was it's
totally different cuz like I'm good at
Tekken but Street Fighter I'm not that
great to include just one Street Fighter
character um your interesting took a
choice it's cool it's not really you
know cuz like everyone oh yeah bit -
yeah - having a kuma in there cuz
throwing in like the worst of the worst
that right there I think it'll work
because they're gonna find a way to
include them in the story and they'll
adjust Akuma to the control plane of
Tekken and just be like okay all we have
to do is adjust a character here for the
Tekken gameplay I think this is the
first time on your show where you can
actually talk more about the game better
because I've never been a fight like a
huge fighting game like of course I love
smash bros yeah um with all my heart
at the same time it's just like I'm
really bad and there's video evidence of
me bad I love that we're starting to see
I guess see more of this like okay to be
like you know like cross-promoting you
know yeah video games and crossovers and
that's for stuff and it's cool to see
like Akuma like in like a Tekken 7 like
Tekken 7 in Mortal Kombat we've got a
ton of like horror villain yeah DLCs I
mean they just added the the [ __ ] the
alien the a there's you know more Z no
more data you know Leatherface I like
what games are doing games are like
making the universes even bigger with
its characters by including other
universes yeah well and I think I think
it's just awesome to kind of like one
promote like both different types games
and different universes but also it's
more about like making a real [ __ ]
cool game and when you can make a real
[ __ ] cool game that includes and
celebrates other games in it it's just
it makes the entire experience better
yeah absolutely
crossover sell games yeah I can awesome
yeah that's why rowan's it's like Marvel
vs. Capcom and stuff oh yeah crossovers
are awesome they're just awesome week
doesn't mean they always work you know
the ideas are always good god it always
sounds early but sometimes in execution
you're like oh I wasn't as cool as it
though yeah that's how it is for most of
the apps I download what like play a
spider-man and Wolverine is just a
resource farmer real yeah Jesus Christ
I'm buying diamonds and [ __ ] like to
play the next level that's good ami that
was [ __ ] worth it I'm you know what
maybe that's my thing I've been trying
to get back any games but I keep doing
like games that other people are playing
I want to [ __ ] fit in but maybe my
thing is fighting games cuz I really
like fighting games a lot yeah I grew up
playing Street Fighter mainly and I like
games like like I grew up playing Street
Fighter Megaman X and Metal Gear Solid
yeah so I like those kinds of games too
like this so I think I should get into
like the Batman games cuz there's
strategy behind it you would really like
those yeah I think fighting games up
maybe they'll be my thing yeah yeah I
think I found my thing you found your
fight you fighting games you got it
congratulations doesn't it feel good
would it be a cool gaming channel if
like would this be different if it was
primarily fighting game base and I will
bring on a guest every time who's
supposedly really good at the game and
then we reverse each other yeah that
worked every cool huh yeah I watch a
Ryan Wright vs. channel yeah i watch the
show
that'd be fun right yeah I won't be on
it because a good man is in this
creative visionary
well visionaries alone Steve Jobs right
here listen guys if you the channel
subscribe to the real rejects oh you
want to because of how [ __ ]
intelligent I am and Dan Seibert has a
gaming channel does a lot of fun
gameplays on there just put up a video
actually that was really impressive was
the title the video I did a
retrospective review it's just playing
an old game and then reviewing it on a
game a game from my childhood called
Teddy Boy it took me a [ __ ] ton of time
to finish it so I really appreciate it
if you go check it out yeah it was
really well scripted a lot of editing
put into it it's almost as much work as
I put into this video right here
hey I had the hardest job I don't know
how I feel the hardest job